- What's up Believe Nation?
I started the MentorMe
series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us,
hang around them a little bit longer,
and by being in their environment,
hopefully some of their
mindsets, their beliefs,
their way of thinking seep into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to learn
how to be unshakable with Tony Robbins.
Mentor me, Tony.
And as always guys, as
you're watchin' the clip,
if you hear somethin' that
really, really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and also when you write it down,
you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
(light, uplifting music)
- Tony, the idea of being unshakeable
is clearly more than
money, but in this context,
what does it truly mean to be unshakeable?
- It's a state of mind.
It relates to money because most people,
when they're trying to
figure out how to create
financial freedom create
more stress for themselves
worrying about what's going on.
And when you're truly
unshakeable you have the mindset
where you understand how the market works,
you understand that real
estate can go up or down,
stocks can go up or down, but
your family can still do well.
Unshakeable is a bear market can come,
a correction can come, and
there's no fear in you,
or if there is a little
fear, we're all human,
you don't stay there, you
find a way to break through,
you find your center.
And when you have that
center, you do what's right
to be able to take care of
yourself and your family.
And I was interviewing
about a year and a half ago,
you know, the former fed
chair, Alan Greenspan,
who for 19 years, the most
powerful man in finance
in the world, under four
different presidents.
Spent five hours with
him, about three privately
and two on stage in front of a group,
and one of my final questions to him,
and we talked about all this crazy change
and all this volatility, and how do people
get things together, I
said, look if you were
back head of the fed
today, what would you do?
And there was this long pause, he paused,
he paused and then he
leaned into me, he said,
Tony, I'd resign (laughing).
And that did not build
much confidence in me
or anybody else who'd be watching.
And yet, in the midst of
all that, as you well know,
there's a few unicorns in the
financial market, very few.
These people that have
found a way to do well
over all the decades, in
good times and in bad.
And they know what it
takes to be unshakeable.
And it isn't just guts or confidence,
it's understanding certain
facts that when you know them,
they free you.
The metaphor I give
people is that, you know,
if you go, and most of us have
heard the old Sufi metaphor
of, you know, the man is walking along
in the middle of the
night and he sees a snake
and freaks out, runs away.
And he comes in in the
morning and what does he see?
It was a rope.
And so once you know it's a rope,
you can be there in
the middle of the night
and you're not scared again.
This book, Unshakeable, is this,
it's really a financial
freedom playbook for anybody.
It's the real essentials about
how to go from where you are
to where you really want to be,
but how to do it with peace of mind.
How to do it even when things are volatile
and enjoy yourself.
I wanted to write a book
that would protect people
because we all know a crash is coming.
And if you're not in the market,
you're still going to experience it
if you're not prepared for it,
because it effects the economy as a whole.
And every five years we have, on average,
we have a bear market or a crash.
And it lasts a year, and it drops 33%.
But every single one of those,
you don't lose any money unless you sell.
And it's really important for
Americans to understand this
because America's unique,
in 2 1/2 centuries,
every crash is followed immediately by
an explosion up and a bull market.
So you all remember 2008, you
remember the market dropped
almost 50% from peak to
trough if you're aware of it.
But from March 9th, what,
a day or two from now,
is the celebration of it, it
went up in the next 12 months
69% and it's been going
up ever since for 250%.
So, you get really wealthy
when those numbers change.
So what I want to do is
free people from the fear,
not by enthusiasm or positive
thinking but by facts.
The facts are, there's
a correction every year.
You shouldn't be surprised
when the market corrects.
Last January was the worst opening
in the history of the stock market,
and we had a record-breaking year.
People lost 2.2 trillion if they sold,
but if they stayed they went nowhere.
So when you know that every single year
there's going to be a correction,
now a correction by the way
means it drops 10 up to 20% from the peak.
A bear market or crash is 20% or more.
But every year since 1900, for 116 years,
we've had a correction, it's like winter,
you're not surprised when winter comes.
Some are long, some are short,
but you know it's coming.
- You've even got a
chapter in the book called
Winter is Coming.
- Yes, yes.
(audience laughing)
It's my HBO special (laughing).
But the reason I say that
is if you know it's coming,
we want to prepare so you're protected,
but also, for everyone listening,
everyone who's joining us
online, think about this,
if you're a millennial, for example,
you got all this debt from college,
it's so imbalanced right now,
and you think you're
never going to get free,
or you're a baby boomer
and you never got started
and you think it's too
late, believe it or not,
the crash, the next crash,
is the greatest opportunity
in your life to leapfrog
from where you are,
where you don't want to be financially,
to where you want to be,
'cause everything goes on sale.
Listen, the ladies in this room,
if your favorite outfits or
shoes are on sale for 50% off
you're pretty damn excited, right?
(audience laughing)
Well guys, if I said to you,
what's your favorite car,
and you said a Ferrari and I
said you get it for 50% off,
guys'd be out of their mind.
But when the stock market
drops 50%, it's on sale,
most people freak out.
Not Warren Buffet, not people like that.
I interviewed a guy named Howard Marks,
he was investing a billion
dollars a week in 2008 and 9,
when the market was through the floor.
And now he's worth a
hundred billion dollars
'cause he bought everything for pennies.
You got to think of it this way,
when things are goin' really great,
what do people want for
the price of their home,
or the price of their
stock, or their business?
Its real value, or more?
When it's going up like crazy,
everybody wants more than it's worth.
When it starts crashing
what will people take
for their car, for their
business, for their stocks,
what will they take?
- [Audience] Anything.
- Anything they can get.
And so those opportunities
are the greatest ones
in your life, and here's
what you got to know,
if you're stressed by
worrying about the market
or the economy, there's
a correction every year,
you're going to be stressed forever.
If you're 35 and you're
going to live to 85,
you got 50 more corrections to go through,
and you know, a bear market
comes every five years,
so you're going to have 10
more bear markets in your life.
Time to stop being stressed,
time to become unshakeable,
which simply means you have a
plan, you know what's going on
you're not fearful 'cause you
know how this works long term
and you're not going to
be taken advantage of,
you're going to take
advantage of the environment.
The goal if you own a business,
and I would assume a lot of
your viewers are business owners
or are getting started in business.
No matter how good you are in
business, think about this,
the one universal rule that
idiots in finance know,
is diversification, it's
the only free lunch,
you got to diversify.
Because if you put all
your eggs in one basket,
no matter how good the basket is,
one day that real estate
market, that stock market,
that bond market, that
collectables market,
whatever you invest in, Ray
Dalio showed me statistically
it'll drop 50 to 70% on a day.
Now, if you're later in
life when that happens,
it's over for you.
So you have to diversify
and yet most people
they know real estate, so they do it,
or they know stocks so they do it,
or they grew up with their
parents flipping things.
And it's the wrong thing to do.
So you've got to diversify in
order for you to be able to
truly succeed, and that's
why when you own a business,
if you put all your
money in your business,
which is what most of do naturally,
perhaps you see a lot.
- A lot of risk.
- You put all your eggs in one basket
and there's things that
can happen, I mean,
you know, let's say you spend 20 years
and you figured out how to
put together the ultimate map.
And you remember Garmin
came out with this thing
called a tomtom, I don't
know if you remember,
you used to put on your,
are you old enough to remember that?
You could put on your phone.
- Of course, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or you just put on your dash.
Cost a hundred bucks,
it was a breakthrough.
- [Lewis] They were makin' like
a hundred million or something, or yeah--
- They were, six months
later, what happened?
- [Lewis] The iPhone came
out with Google Maps.
- That's right, these little
bastards, excuse my French,
came out with it, put Google Maps,
put their own map on here,
and it cost how much?
Zero.
What's that going to do to your business
when someone takes your product or service
and gives it away for free?
So I always tell people,
competition happens,
technology happens, what you must do
is have a second business
with no moving parts,
no people, no time, maybe it takes you
two, three days a year
for two or three hours
after you've read the book.
You put it in place and you measure it
two or three times a year, that's it.
Go on with your life.
Now if there's a trouble in your business,
you're financially set.
I, in my life, have 31 companies now.
We have, what do we have, 1200 employees,
7 different industries, we
do five billion in sales.
I mean I, that used to be
me and my seminar business.
It's grown geometrically.
But with all those moving parts,
the only way I've been able to succeed
is because I've taken
everyone of those businesses
and I've diversified my assets so that
when things were in trouble,
I still had enough economics
to take care of myself and
keep the business going.
So, everybody needs to
create a money machine,
that works while you sleep,
that doesn't have moving parts,
and that's what this is really about.
- Can you talk about what it
means to discuss the market
as a game and how that might
be a dangerous concept?
- Sure, first of all, the
reason I called the other book
Money Master the Game is
that every wealthy person
I interviewed called it
a game, every single one.
And other people were
saying, that's irresponsible,
that's horrible to call it a game,
this is the dumbest thing, that's a,
but see, that mindset
is what's keeping you
from investing in the first place.
So, you can be in a game,
it can be a difficult game.
The challenging games are usually the ones
that we like the most.
But this is a game that
can reward your family
disproportionately to any
other game that's out there.
Now, some people play games aggressively,
some play things more in a secure way.
Your style is more secure.
And what I teach in this book is
we want to have a style
that makes you feel good
'cause you may make a bunch of money
but you're stressed all the
time, it's not worth it.
There's a way to make money your slave,
instead of you being the slave to money.
But let me explain.
It's not put all your money in the market.
It's really two things.
It's first, you've got to
decide the most important
financial decision of your life,
and that is to become an
owner and not just a consumer.
If you have a, I see a bunch
of iPhones recording this
right now--
- [Interviewer] And just watch your foot,
'cause there's glass of water there--
- Yeah, thank you for catchin' that.
If you're a, yeah, I'm an active human
so things move around with me.
But if you got an iPhone
and you don't own Apple,
or better yet, you don't own
the index to the S&P 500,
the best 500 companies,
you're makin' a giant mistake.
'Cause you'll never earn your
way to financial fortune.
Even people that make just loads of money,
the actors, the actresses, the athletes,
where are they 10 and 15 years later?
I mean, 50 Cent made a
hundred million dollars
on vitamin water, he got
a tip, and he got like a
2 or 300 million dollar net
worth and he's bankrupt.
He bought Mike Tyson's
house, 25,000 square feet,
and Mike Tyson made a
half a billion dollars
and went bankrupt.
Right now, I don't know
if you saw, Johnny Depp,
I don't know if it's
going to happen or not,
but the papers are saying
he may go bankrupt.
He made 3/4 of a billion
dollars as a movie star
but he spent $30,000 a month on wine,
he must be feelin' good, and secondly,
he took Hunter Thompson, the reporter,
he burned his body and paid
$3 million to blow his ashes
into the sky in a cannon.
So, no matter how much money you make,
you can screw it up, right?
But if you will just decide,
there's a percentage of my
income that no matter what,
I'm going to have it automated,
I'm not going to see it,
it's going to go straight
to an investment account.
And I don't know if it's 10 or 15 or 20,
those numbers sound
gigantic to most people.
Even if you start with five and build,
that income does not go to anybody else
and then you put that into compounding.
So listen to this, there's
a young man, true story,
a Theodore Johnson, 1950s, worked for USP,
never made more than
$14,000 in annual income
in his entire life,
retired with $70 million
and he didn't inherit a dime.
He gave away 35 million
while he was alive.
Now how is that possible?
Because of compound interest.
When I interview all
these investors and say,
what's the biggest mistake Americans make?
He said, they all said,
they don't tap into compound interest.
They know intellectually a
little bit what it means,
but they don't do it.
They don't do it consistently.
So what do you do--
- It basically just means
that the profits you make
can go back into the investment.
- You keep reinvesting
and it keeps growing
but it grows geometrically, right.
And so, a friend of his came
to this man who worked for UPS
and said, "I'm going to make you rich.
"We're going to put a 20% tax on you."
And he said, "I can't give up 20%,
"I can't pay my bills if I do that."
He said, "Listen, if the
government raised your taxes 20%,
"and you'd claim, you'd scream, you'd cry,
"you'd complain, and you'd pay it,
"and you'd get adjusted to it."
But he said, "This is not
goin' to the government.
"This is goin' into an
account for your future."
And that compounding is what
made him that much money.
In the book I give you an
example of an 18-year-old boy
whose father convinces
him that he should save
$300 a month out of his income.
It's not a huge income,
that sounds like a lot.
But when you automate it, you
forget about it, it's perfect.
You adjust.
Well, he does this from
18 years old to 27,
for eight years.
So the total amount of
money, $300 a month,
it's about 4000 a year,
that's $28,000 total.
He then puts, he leaves it in the market
and never adds a dime to
it from 28 years old on.
At 65, because the market
over those 30 years
grew 10%, his money has compounded so much
that he has $1.8 million.
You don't need a lot of money
to be wealthy, you need time.
- So you're saying that
even if I have student debt
that I'm struggling to pay off,
even if I'm making say, a
thousand dollars a week,
that I should still try
to put a percentage,
or make it a point to put a percentage,
not just into a savings account,
but into an investment account.
- Into an investment account,
where to put that money then
we teach you the ways to do that,
and it's got to be diversified.
Never put all your money
in the market, right.
- I want to, okay.
- What are the five
takeaways that somebody can
take from this book where
they can really put them
actually into action?
- Well I'll tell you the four things that,
I interviewed these 50
unbelievable investors,
had in common, they're all different.
You know I interviewed people
that are macro traders.
I interviewed people like
Warren Buffet, right,
value people.
I interviewed people that
it's blood in the streets
type of people, you buy when
the world is going to hell.
And they're all different,
but they had four things
in common real fast.
Number one, every single
one of them was obsessed
with not losing money.
Guys like you and I tend to say,
how do we make money for our
companies, for ourselves,
as an investor.
Their entire focus is not losing money
because they know if you lose
50%, it takes 100% get even.
- [Interviewer] Well, it's about becoming
comfortable with risk.
- Well it's more than that,
these guys are obsessed with
not being comfortable with risk,
they don't want to take risk,
and the second key that they do
is they all are focused on
asymmetrical risk reward.
Most people think the
most successful investors
take huge risks to get huge rewards.
And in reality, they take the
least risk humanly possible
to get the largest upside.
So their whole focus is how
do I get a three to one,
or a five to one?
If I risk a dollar trying
to make five and I'm wrong,
I can risk ano-, I can be wrong
four times and break even.
So they have a completely
different approach.
They're all very focused
thirdly on tax efficiency
because you only have the
money you get to keep.
And fourthly it's all diversification.
And those four things fundamentally
are the frame from which you
start to design a portfolio.
- How did you go from
basically not having a hot meal
to you know, basically being a guru,
an international guru,
doling out financial advice?
- Well it's interesting, I was just,
Worth magazine just
named me their Power 100,
it was the 100 most influential
people on global finance,
along with Carl, all
the guys I interviewed.
But part of it is I believe in modeling,
I believe success leaves clues.
If someone has done very well financially
for decade after decade,
they're not lucky,
they're doin' something different.
If someone is fit and healthy,
and they've managed it
for 20 years, they're lucky,
they got a great relationship,
they're not lucky.
So I'm really good at deciphering
what those things are.
So I would sit down with
someone like Jack Bogle,
you know, who built, you know
$3 trillion industry, right,
you know everybody's doing their Vanguard.
And I'm suppose to have
a 45 minute interview
and we go four hours, and he says,
he's been in the business 65 years,
and in the book he says it
was the most penetrating,
emotional dr- interview
he's ever done in his life,
'cause I kind of extract
it out of their brain
and then make it simple
so you can apply it.
- So thank you guys so much for watching,
I'd love to know, what did
you learn from this video?
What clip spoke to you the most?
And what are you going
to take from these clips
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super-curious to find out.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out to
TridentLion, thank you
so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and for making that awesome
YouTube video on it as well.
I really appreciate the support,
and I'm glad that you enjoyed the book.
- [Narrator] Today this video
is all about Your One Word.
(upbeat music)
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.